Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in
the chapter of vigilance of Allah's
observation authored by Muhamad Ali
al- Abu
Zakaria
he mentions the ninth narration in this
chapter. This narration is on the
authority of Omar.
[Silence]
Omar Hisa
is what?
His kuna.
Yes. Correct. And his his date of
death.
Which year did he pass away?
12 and change. Yeah. So
man, you're so close. What' you say?
[Arabic recitation]
So
after the prophet's death. Sai wasallam.
How long was his
[Arabic recitation]
10 years long along with 2 and a2 years
of Abu Bakr's
10 years and change roughly 23 after
hijra 23 after hijra he died at 63 the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam died
at 63 Abu Bakr died at 63 Omar died at
63 Three.
He narrates that the prophet Sam
said.
This narration was collected by Abu Dud
which translates roughly to a man is
not to be asked about his reprimand
of his wife. Now this narration
is not an authentic narration. It has
weakness in its chain similar to the
weakness found in the narration of Abu
Bakr
that we took before.
weak. This weakness is slight, but
notice what Noah always says here. I'm
going to give you this point and I want
you to remember it. Okay? If we were to
say, what are the six
references of hadith? What are the six
what are referred to as
the references of the books of
what are they? Can we mention them? les
alkari
Muslim
Abu DB.
Okay. So those are the six books. If you
hear a scholar say the seven books, it
includes Musad Ahmed. If you hear them
say the eight books, it includes
but usually it is the six books. Okay,
these six books, why are they called the
six mother books of hadith or the six
references or the six the six
references. The reason is when we take
all the narrations in these books and we
take all of the mut meaning the words
that are ascribed as being the prophet's
words, the prophet's actions, the
prophet's anything having to do with
him. It becomes part of the sunnah and
we remove repetition.
Okay? And we remove chains of narration.
This gives us the bulk majority of all
of the prophet sunnah. Not all of it,
not every last narration,
not every last statement or action, but
the bulk majority.
Okay,
this makes up the bulk majority of the
prophet sunnah. The first scholar to
consider these six books in this way is
and after that all of the scholars
followed in suit. Now these books are
not all authentic compilations.
Books of hadith are of different types.
Imagine
imagine tools. You have a ratchet, you
have a a hammer, you have a screwdriver,
you have a Phillips, you have sockets,
you have wrenches, you have Okay, these
books have different roles that they
fill. The author intended this to be a
tool for a specific task.
Bkari and Muslim are authentic
compilations. What does that mean? It
means
he compiled in his book. Every narration
every narration in that book he is
grading as authentic.
Muslim did the same thing. Everything in
this book is authentic according to the
following set of criteria.
Now the rest of the
sun
these are a different type of book are
these books are referred to as
what is a book of sunn it's a type of
book of hadith book of sunnen
is a book that essentially deals with
aim
rulings,
okay? Rulings,
woo, salah, fasting, etc. All the way
through jihad, inheritance,
from the beginning to the end, this is
what it is dealing with. Now,
the author of a sunn his job is to
is to u compile
compile as many
as many sunen
which is plural for sunnah as many
sun as he can and then he'll mention a
chapter. So for instance he'll say the
book of salah then he'll mention
chapters in that book this is the book
of the times of salah this is the or
this is the chapter of the time of the
chapter of the time of the chapter of
the time of etc. You get the point. And
the point here is that the narration
he'll mention
is going to be the strongest narration
in that subject
and he will mention in his book as many
said rulings and sunnen as he can
whatever the scholars differ on. Right?
So for instance, one of the things that
the scholars have have mentioned, the
jurists of Islam have mentioned is not
using siwek, not brushing one's teeth.
If you're fasting after the sun crosses
noon,
after noon, after the sun crosses its
zenith, before you use after
you don't, this is an opinion, okay?
It's a it's a it's a claim made by some
jurists. Where do they get this from?
Well, they get this generally from the
narration of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam that
the smell of the
stomach of a person who is fasting
is more beloved to Allah than the scent
of musk. We know this narration,
correct? And so they say, when does this
smell occur? It occurs most prominently
after the first half of the day.
Therefore, if a person brushes his
teeth, he gets rid of this smell. No, we
should keep the smell. This is a weak
opinion. It is a weak opinion, but it's
an opinion.
So, what will the scholar who's writing
a book on Sunn do? He'll mention that
opinion and then he'll mention the
strongest evidence used by jurists as an
evidence for that opinion.
He's not saying the opinion is correct.
He's not even claiming the narration is
cor is authentic. He is merely
documenting
this field the field of the field of.
So Abu Dani
he authors his book as sunani
one of the most greatest scholars that
have ever walked the earth. one of the
most prominent students of Albkari
rather one of the most prominent
students of Imam Ahmed as well. He was
old enough to have taken from Imam Ahmed
as well. Now
Abu Dani
he authors his book and he includes
narrations. He mentions their chain of
narration. Is he saying that every time
he he he documents an irration, is he
saying it's authentic?
No. No. He's documenting opinions and
their evidences. That's it. Doesn't mean
everything in the book is authentic. He
is going to mention the strongest
narration in that field. The strongest
narration in that issue might be weak.
The strongest narration in that issue
might be very weak. We understand that.
Therefore,
the scholars of hadith have different
types of books that they write. This
narration we just heard is from Sunb
Noahi died at what age?
Anyone know?
Mid4s. 45. Exactly. 45 years old. and he
started officially seeking knowledge
at the age of 18.
He had memorized the Quran, but he
hadn't studied yet. 18. That gives him
how many years of studying?
26 years roughly because he went for
Hajj with his father. When he's coming
back 19 years old, he started seeking
knowledge. About 26 years. 26 years in
the world of scholars is a little
toddler still that is in time.
Okay. Now he managed to become a major
scholar in that time.
However, that usually is a very short
amount of time and there's only so much
you can do physically in that amount of
time. And one of those things is go
through every single narration that you
use and authenticate it. How impossible
would that be,
right? You're writing a book Alm,
okay? Just to get from the chapters of
wudoo and so forth to the chapter of
janaza, we've got 10 volumes. That's how
big this book is. All right. How many
narrations are mentioned in that book?
Thousands.
How could he possibly have time to
authenticate every single narration? And
some narrations are so particular
that they may take weeks to authenticate
and come to a conclusion on.
Therefore, he has to rely on the
authentication of what? Of others.
And two of the major scholars that he
relied on their authentication was Abu
Di
and
is a little bit lax in his
authentication.
He might his his threshold for
authenticity is
much lower. It's easier. it's mo
most of the scholars who are moderate
would disagree with some of his
authentications
and so as a result of that the narration
we heard yesterday
or the day before
he views this as acceptable
the majority of the scholars of hadith
views view this as what inauthentic
Abu D is the same thing. He relied on
Abu Dhistani
that if Abu D didn't point out that a
narration is flawed, he accepts it
and this is due to his experience with
Abi but he didn't specialize in the book
and so weaken narrations found their way
into his work. But as we said before
yesterday, one of the most beautiful
things about
is that there are no narrations which
are agreed upon as being rejected.
There are no fabricated narrations.
There are no extremely weak narrations.
And the next thing is all of the
narration's meanings are what? Correct.
So the narration itself may not be
authentic but the meaning is what is
correct. This narration is inauthentic.
The majority of the of hadith have
graded this narration as being is but
the weakness is slight but the meaning
the spirits of the narration.
A man is not to be asked why he has
reprimanded his wife by the meaning of
the narration. What is the spirit of the
narration? The spirit of the narration
is
the human being, a couple, a man and
his wife, they have a right to privacy.
Prying into that is not the right of any
other person.
It is the right of the husband, the
right of the wife. If there is a
wrongdoing, then the proper channels for
that is the court, the Muslim court.
There are to be notified and brought
into the situation and they then will
investigate what is going on in that
household. However, Tom, Dick, and Harry
and the guy walking outside and the guy,
this is none of the none of their
business. People have an innate inherent
right to privacy that is part of their
dignity.
And a man is the the sultan or the
caretaker and the superior in his
household. He has a right to that
privacy and he has a right to that
discretion and a mother with her
children and so forth. Therefore, it is
impermissible for a person to pry into
those things. And if a person does, they
are overstepping their bounds. Why does
that fall into the chapter of vigilance
of Allah? Is that as the prophet said in
the narration we took yesterday,
It is of the perfection and the
discipline of a man's Islam that he
leave off what does not concern him. If
a person were to think that there is
some kind of abuse or some kind in this
case, they would go to the right
channels or the the tribe of the the
wife or go to the
Muslim court system. They would go
through that and make some kind of these
are the ways the channels to go through
that. Not seeing the guy down the road.
You know what? I heard this and I heard
that and I wonder what they're doing. I
wonder what they're saying. This is not
the proper channel and this is something
that a person must be vigilant of.